bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
et sur public sénat tout au long du mois
de septembre je vous propose de voir et
de revoir les moments forts de la séance
lors de la dernière session
parlementaire car tout au long du mois
de septembre les sénateurs sont absents
du palais du luxembourg car elles sont
en campagne pour les prochaines
élections sénatoriales qui se tiennent
le 28 septembre prochain et qui
permettront de renouveler la moitié de
la haute assemblée
place ce matin à une proposition de loi
très concernante elle porte sur le
développement et l'encadrement des
stages à l'initiative des sénateurs est
bien de nombreuses améliorations ont été
apportées au stage avec notamment une
augmentation de la gratification du
stage qui est passé de 436 à 523 euros
par mois une limitation du nombre de
stagiaires qui doit être limitée à 10%
des effectifs d'une entreprise est
également en limitant la durée des
stages qui ne doivent pas excéder six
mois tout de suite donc retour aux
discussions au sénat début mai trois
amendements font l'objet d'une
discussion commune l'amendement un
rectifié bis qui est présenté par la
peur merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues le
présent amendement concerne les
modalités d'encadrement et d'intégration
au cursus pédagogique des stages pour
les élèves fonctionnaires et les élèves
en formation pour l'obtention d'un grade
de master les formations ne certains
corps de fonctionnaires comporte des
stages ayant des modalités spécifiques
la longue durée par exemple les
fonctionnaires en formation initiale
ayant le statut de fonctionnaires
stagiaires ne sont pas sujets à haut
risque de précarisation des stagiaires
qui fait l'objet de la présente
proposition de loi par ailleurs les
stages longs en entreprise de ses futurs
fonctionnaires leur permettent de mieux
connaître les environnements avec
lesquels ils seront amenés à travailler
et sont donc encouragés il en est de
même pour les élèves suivre une
formation de niveau master dans tous les
établissements de l'enseignement
supérieur qui ne font pas partie de la
population généralement sujettes au
risque de précarisation des stagiaires
ainsi permettre aux conseils
d'administration des établissements de
l'enseignement supérieur de définir les
modalités de ce stage facilitera une
meilleure prise en compte de leurs
spécificités et un décret risquerait
d'introduire davantage de rigidités et
de complexité dans le dispositif
merci chers collègues des amendements 71
72 sont présentés par monsieur savary
peut-être présenté les 2 en même temps
et on ressemble terriblement à celui
proposé par françoise férat donc je
considère qu'il n'est défendu quant aux
72 il consiste à faire que on insère 2
alinéa après la linea 11 notamment
stipulant que les conseils
d'administration de tous les
établissements de l'enseignement
supérieur définisse les modalités
d'encadrement et d'intégration au cursus
pédagogique des stages et des périodes
de formation en milieu professionnel
pour les formations de ces
établissements donnant lieu à la
délivrance d'un diplôme de master en
effet
notamment pour les cadres les stages à
l'étranger il peut y avoir des durées
qui sont différentes d'un établissement
à l'autre selon les différents cursus
bien entendu
les étudiants accomplissez également
parfois leur année de master et ne sont
pas forcément exposé à des conditions de
stage identique et les règles en vigueur
sont en l'occurrence suffisante pour
garantir leurs droits en conséquence
plutôt qu'un décret qui manqueraient de
souplesse il serait préférable de
permettre aux conseils d'administration
des établissements supérieurs dont cadré
eux-mêmes les modalités de cet âge d'or
étudiants inscrits en master afin de
respecter la spécificité
de leur formation donc cet amendement
reprend l'esprit d'un amendement du
rapporteur concernant la fixation du
nombre de stagiaires suivi par un même
tuteur et les souhaits exprimés par les
représentants de la cpu lors de
l'audition organisée par le rapporteur
prise en compte des auditions ont été
faites
il cher collègue monsieur le rapporteur
quel est l'avis de la commission
l'amendement donc de maldini les
rectifier donc cet amendement vise à
exonérer les établissements délivrant
une formation de niveau master surtout
des grandes écoles et se formant les
futurs fonctionnaires des dispositions
générales relatives à l'intégration des
stages dans un cursus avec le même
volume logique minimale qui sera requis
à la durée maximale du stage en leur
laissant la possibilité à chacun des
défis liés à mon sens cet amendement ne
va pas dans la bonne direction tout
d'abord les élèves des écoles de la
fonction publique et les périodes
d'application qui ont un vrai qu'ils ont
à réaliser durant leur scolarité ne sont
pas dans le champ de la proposition doit
en effet ils n'ont pas proprement parler
un statut d'étudiant ce sont le plus
souvent des fonctionnaires stagiaires ou
à polytechnique des élèves officiers et
qui ont vocation est titularisé au terme
de leur scolarité dans un corps de la
fonction publique et sont donc rémunéré
comme tel de l'amas de manière plus
générale je ne pense pas qu'il faille
s'affranchir la durée maximale de six
mois partage au delà des apports
pédagogiques sont limitées mais il peut
se substituer à un emploi salarié si on
fait une exception pour les grandes
écoles pourquoi la refuser pour d'autres
cursus donc c'est un avis défavorable de
la commission et les deux amendements 71
et 72 sont identiques il redécoupe
l'amendement de madame dini en deux
abondements donc ces avis défavorable
pour les trois merci mme la ministre
quel est l'avis du gouvernement
le gouvernement partage les arguments
développés par monsieur le rapporteur
puisque les stages de fonctionnaire
stagiaire même s'il porte le nom de
stage sont en fait une période
probatoire prévu par les statuts
particuliers pour une application des
lois de 1983 et 1984 pour la fonction
publique et qui doivent permettre
ensuite la titularisation dans un corps
de fonctionnaires ils ne sont absolument
pas concernés donc par ce proposition de
loi en ce qui concerne les masters
on sait que lorsque la période de stage
excès de six mois pendant un master cela
équivaut à une un test de pré embauche
et c'est pourquoi nous ne pouvons pas
choisi de ne pas autoriser de
dérogations pour les masters c'est
contraire à l'esprit de la définition du
stage tels que nous telle qu'elle est
conçue telle qu'elle est conçue
d'ailleurs par les partenaires sociaux
est partagé par la cpu c'est pourquoi je
suis un peu surprise de vos propos parce
que nous avons fait tous en accord avec
l'ensemble des acteurs et il ne
souhaitait pas que nous
élargissions au delà de six mois la
période de stage pour les masters donc
avis défavorable effectivement pour les
3 à moment merci madame ferrer pour
explication de vote
oui monsieur le président je suis assez
gêné parce que je ne suis pas l'auteur
de cet amendement et ça m'ennuie
beaucoup d'avoir une position
trancher simplement je pense que dit
madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur et j'ai le sentiment que
voilà ce problème est déjà pris en
compte par ailleurs et de ce fait je
retire mon amendement merci chers
collègues même chose
les amendements sont retirés
nous en arrivons à l'amendement numéro 8
qui est présentée par monsieur désessard
que le site je sois bien au service d'un
projet pédagogique
la présente proposition de loi propose
d'établir un seuil minimal de formation
que l'étudiant doit effectuer avant de
bénéficier d'une convention de stage
cette mesure un double avantage d'une
part lutter contre les offres de
formation factice notamment sur internet
qui propose aux étudiants dans la
réalité d'acheter convention de stage
sans leur fournir le moindre
enseignement
d'autre part limiter les pratiques de
certaines universités qui propose des
diplômes dont la seule utilité d'ouvrir
le droit à une convention de stage
donc nous sommes d'accord avec le
principe défini dans cette proposition
de loin cette fois le seuil minimal de
formation est renvoyé à un décret nous
considérons que le seuil peut être
défini dans le texte à 200 heures par 2
200 heures 200 heures de formation c'est
seulement deux mois et demi de formation
à raison de 20 heures par semaine ce
chiffre nous sommes raisonnables et
adaptée pour lutter efficacement
contre les offres de formation factice
donc voilà l'amendement propose de
préciser aujourd'hui
le seuil minimal de formation qui
correspond à l'esprit de la proposition
de loi
merci monsieur rapportant l'avis de la
commission
nous propose de fixer à 200 heures le
volume pédagogique minimal de formation
d'établissement qui doit accompagner un
stage je rejoins cet amendement dans son
esprit néanmoins le renvoi voie
réglementaire de la fixation ce volume
de la logique minimale me semble
justifier tout n'a pas à figurer dans la
loi en particulier des mesures
d'application comme celle ci mais je
suis certain que le gouvernement pourra
nous apporter des précisions sur son
attention et c'est une demande de
retrait
merci madame la ministre quel est l'avis
des gouvernements
vernement partage l'avis du rapporteur
là encore nous avons voulu que la série
puisse le ca puissent voter en toute
connaissance de cause donc nous avons
souhaité être transparents les
négociations qui sont en cours nous
allen
proposer un volume de formation de 200
heures d'au moins 200 heures ça peut
être davantage bien évidemment les
minimum de 200 heures afin d'éviter
effectivement les offres de formation
alléchante qui comporte assez peu de
formation est quasiment que du stage et
qui en général les ans on ne sont pas
gratuites en ce qui concerne ces
formations et vous les avez j'imagine
tous à l'esprit mais ça relève
effectivement du niveau réglementaire et
pour ces raisons je vous demande de
retirer cet amendement sinon je serais
obligée d'émettre un avis défavorable
merci chers collègues
merci chers collègues nous en arrivons à
l'amendement 108 rectifié biz présentée
par monsieur sabri
voilà un amendement qui va intéresser
madame la ministre bien entendu
puisqu'il vise à encadrer les organismes
de formation et les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur privé afin de
parer à la vente de conventions de stage
il s'agit d'insérer un article bien
précis comme quoi le rectorat et
l'inspection académique effectué au
minimum un contrôle au sein des
organismes de formation des
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
privé cela une régularité fixé par
décret afin de s'assurer de la bonne
mise en oeuvre des cours souscrit lors
de l'inscription et des diplômes associé
aux enseignements et pour mieux les
convaincre il est proposé une amende
administratif en effet c'est l'objet de
cet amendement certains établissements
d'enseignement supérieur privé libre où
certains organismes de formation peuvent
sur demande des livres une convention de
stage d'une durée de 1 à 6 mois dans
plusieurs secteurs d'activité et les
faits révèle que le délai d'obtention de
conventions de stages et cours et le
stage peut commencer immédiatement
moyennant d'importants frais relatifs à
l'achat desdites conventions dissimulés
sous des inscriptions à des formations
au sein de ces établissements
donc c'est véritablement un amendement
qui consiste à encadrer les mauvaises
pratiques
merci cher collègue monsieur rapporteur
quel est l'avis de la commission
de la commission partage avec les
auteurs de cet amendement l'idée qu'il
faut renforcer les contrôles à l'égard
de certains organismes qui doutaient
seulement d'une boîte aux lettres vente
des conventions de stage néanmoins je ne
sais pas comment articuler seul avec le
principe fondamental de la liberté de
l'enseignement supérieur je ne suis pas
certain non plus que l'inspection
académique et la capacité juridique
d'infliger des amendes administratives
en la matière les vrais escroquerie
relève de la répression des fraudes plus
que du contrôle pédagogique il a semblé
nécessaire à la commission de demander
l'avis du gouvernement afin qu'il nous
précise les initiatives qu'il pourrait
prendre pour lutter contre ces officines
c'est monsieur le rapporteur madame ce
truc quel est l'avis du gouvernement
en fait l'objet de l'amendement qui est
de mettre fin à des pratiques plus que
douteuses
nous partageons mais les dispositions
prises dans la loire et en particulier
l'existence d'un volume
de formation minimum permet déjà de
répondre à ces deux d'empêcher ces
pratiques frauduleuses par ailleurs ça
pousse soudain un problème que de
transformer les services administratifs
du rectorat qui sont des services de
contrôle
en des services en quelque sorte de
police qui mettrait des amendes je crois
que ça n'est pas du tout conforme aux
compétences des rectorats et encore une
fois l'objet puisque vous regardez le
fond des choses l'objet c'est empêcher
les pratiques frauduleuses et on les
empêche en mettant un certain nombre de
dispositions qui font que elles ne
pourront plus avoir lieu
et naturellement pour les inspections
nous y sommes et pour la fréquence des
inspections nous y sommes tout à fait
favorables pour toutes ces raisons
je propose le rejet de cet amendement
merci monsieur fabre et les populations
de vote
j'aurais madame la ministre permettez
moi d'insister mais rappelé que s'il est
proposé une amende administrative il
n'est pas dit que ce soit le rectorat
qui en a la charge je crois que le
rectorat et l'inspection d'académie
effectivement doivent contrôler et faire
en sorte qu' il n'y a pas d'organisme du
bidon en somme qui vendent des stages à
des prix parfois premier mythifié nos
étudiants sont les premières victimes
quoi enfin le stagiaire soyons précis
dans le vocabulaire
c'est pas préciser que c'est le seul
inspections d'académie leur victoire
donc je crois que à chaque
administré administration à ses propres
responsabilités il un père tient au
rectorat l'inspection de l'académie
d'avertir
le ministère concerné j'en sais rien moi
aussi c'est l'inspection du travail je
ne sais qui qui doivent vérifier que la
pratique est ou non frauduleuse 1 par
contre par contre par contre ça pourrait
mettre fin à quelque chose qui nous a
été largement signalé qu est cette
pratique de vente de stage parce qu'on
sait que des stages sont obligatoires
donc on peut trouver sur des organismes
plus ou moins d'un veillant ou plutôt
malveillants qui exploite
je dirais nono étude no nos stagiaires
parce que ils sont confrontés aux
difficultés que l'on a déjà largement
évoqué c'est la raison pour laquelle
madame le ministre je pense que cet
amendement peut être votée sans état
d'âme
merci chers collègues je n'ai pas
d'autres demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter cet
amendement veuille bien levé la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre veuille
bien levé la main
l'amendement n'est pas adopté deux
amendements font l'objet d'une
discussion commune sommes nous
commençons par l'amendement 73 qui est
présenté par madame professeurs
cet amendement vise tout simplement à
rétablir la rédaction de l'article l de
106 112 2 du code de l'éducation telle
qu'elle était prévue dans la loi
cherpion de 2011
on se demande pourquoi on rédige une
nouvelle loi qui renvoie à beaucoup de
décret alors que il aurait suffi que les
décrets prévus dans la loi cherpion soit
pris ils ont pas été pris loi de 2011
certes en partie par le gouvernement
précédent mais pas non plus par le
gouvernement actuel
cet amendement vise à revoir les
dérogations possibles de la durée
maximum de 6 mois parce que dans un
certain nombre de formations et elles
nous ont écrit et elles ont dû vous
écrire il y à des formations qui sont
prévues pédagogiquement et qui sont des
formations de huit mois donc il va
falloir revoir tout le cursus
pédagogique d'un certain nombre de ces
formations uniquement pour rentrer dans
le cadre de la loi c'est en particulier
le cas du domaine social et d'ailleurs
dans la loi madame la ministre que vous
avez défendu il y a quelques mois
les ces formations étaient bien connus
pour avoir des durée de neuf mois
là aussi vous m'avez répondu on a parti
qu'il y aurait des avancées mais qu'en
est il pour les années de césure des
années de césure qui existe à la fois
dans les grandes écoles mais qui existe
aussi dans les établissements
publics d'enseignement supérieur qui
nous ont dit accorder systématiquement
l'année de césure quand un étudiant la
demande est pour aller effectuer
effectivement des stages et enfin
dernier élément de cet amendement de
supprimer la disposition transitoire de
deux ans qui était prévu dans la
proposition de loi
parce que elle serait dommageable à tous
les publics de nous que nous avons cités
merci chers collègues l'amendement 43
rectifiée présentée par monsieur barbier
et monsieur le président le ministre
effectivement je crois qu'on aborde le
problème de cette rigidité qu'entraîne
la fixation de six mois de la durée des
stages et tout d'abord cet amendement
43,7 peu partie d'une série
d'amendements qui sera présenté en vue
d'exclure les périodes de formation en
milieu professionnel réalisé dans le
cadre de l'alternance colère les
dispositions de la proposition de loi
ces derniers en effet sont inadaptées à
l'alternance colère en matière de durée
maximale puisque la période de formation
et les enseignements sont effectuées
simultanément sur une année scolaire
ainsi la durée maximale de six mois est
automatiquement dépasser le présent
amendement il a été évoqué le problème
des maisons familiales rurales notamment
des stages en matière agricole ou en
matière de
formation d'un service à la personne le
présente à m'en demande et à tenir
compte de cette spécificité de ces
formations
représentent le suivant absolument le
deuxième bassin concerne l'enseignement
supérieur puisque la loi entend cadre et
le recours abusif aux stages en limitant
six mois la durée maximale de stage pour
toutes les filières de formation la loi
de 22 juillet 2013 relatives à
l'enseignement supérieur à la recherche
madame le ministre adopte est une
approche plus équilibrée de cette
limitation en prévoyant des exceptions
fixé par décret pour tenir compte des
spécificités de certaines filières de
formation ce texte tire un trait sur
cette possibilité à part au lieu
d'adapter le stage à l'information ce
qui aurait été plus logique c'est la
formation qui doit s'adapter aux
dispositions relatives aux stages c'est
un peu curieux or cette généralisation
est dangereuse pour toutes les
formations dont la pratique occupent une
large place dans le cursus j'ai déjà
cité dans des jets la psychologie où
seule une pratique important permet
d'acquérir les compétences
indispensables afin de préparer les
étudiants à exercer ce métier
en outre cette proposition de loi met en
péril sa vient d'être évoquée par
catherine procast ya les années de
césure
proposées par les écoles de commerce
certaines écoles d'ingénieurs le présent
amendement propose ainsi de porter la
durée maximale du stage un nom pour
tenir compte de ses spécificités
je sais que c'est un peu difficile par
rapport aux tests présentés mais je
crois qu'on rencontrera beaucoup de
difficultés dans certaines filières dans
cet effet
l'amendement 38 je le présente aussi
visuel président s'il voulait
oui je me suis fait une petite pause non
non pour les raisons que j'ai évoquées
donc dans la présentation de cet
amendement je proposerai d'établir les
dispositions en vigueur relative à la
durée maximale des stages tel qu'il
résulte de la loi du 22 juillet 2013
relatives à l'enseignement supérieur et
la recherche les exceptions la durée
maximale de six mois seront ainsi fixés
par décret pour les formations dont les
spécificités requiert une durée de
pratiques supérieur en outre il me
semble nécessaire de consulter les
filières de formation ça a été évoqué
précédemment sur un autre problème
concernant ces dérogations plus ces
filières sont plus à même de juger du
poids de la pratique au sein de la
formation tel est l'objet de la présente
amendement numéro 38 merci chers
collègues nous revenons donc aux 144 il
est présenté par monsieur le rapporteur
au nom de la commission
c'est un manque de coordination
et donc nous enchaînons sur deux
amendements identiques que le premier et
le sang par monsieur marseille il n'est
pas défendu le deuxième de 127 rectifier
et présentée par monsieur savary
oui merci monsieur le président c'est un
amendement qui vise à renforcer la
qualité des stages et notamment en
renforçant les échanges entre
l'établissement d'accueil et
l'établissement de formation
effectivement en vertu de la loi sur
l'enseignement supérieur recherche de
juillet 2013 toutes élèves et étudiants
ayant achevé son stage transmet aux
services de son établissement
d'enseignement chargé de l'accompagner
un document dans lequel il évalue la
qualité de l'accueil dont il a bénéficié
au niveau 2 au sein de l'organisme il
est donc souhaitable que l'organisme
d'accueil de stagiaires soit rendu
destinataire de ce document afin qu'il
puisse en tenir compte dans sa politique
de stage et assurer une qualité que l'on
recherche à travers ces stages de
formation
merci chers collègues nous en arrivons
33 rectifié monsieur le score nul
merci monsieur le président la ministre
chaque collègue là encore il faut voir
dans cette proposition un amendement qui
tend à conforter les stages en
entreprise en réaffirmant le fait qu'ils
ne doivent être dédiée complété par
l'immersion et la pratique
professionnelle des compétences
théoriques sentiment dispense dispensés
à l'université on sait que cela n'est
pas nécessairement toujours le cas et
les exemples sont nombreux malgré les
évolutions législatives déjà intervenu
d'un d'étudiants inscrits dans des
diplômes fantômes dans le seul but de
bénéficier d'une convention de stage
afin de remédier à cette situation nous
proposons de préciser dans la loi que la
durée du stage ne peut pas excéder la
durée de la formation pédagogique qui en
quelque 100 lui sert de support il
s'agit d'éviter le cas de formation
université a composé de seulement
quelques semaines de cours et passe dans
l'année qui permet deux écoles et
universités d'engranger des frais
d'inscription parfois importants pour
des dépenses pédagogique de et de
fonctionnement faible voire parfois nul
qui donne l'impression que les
établissements d'enseignement
je prête au contournement de la loi on a
six
merci lamont 75 rectifier et présenté
par alain bigueur
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre madame la présidente monsieur
mes chers collègues le droit actuel fixe
le principe d'une durée maximale de
stage à six mois cet amendement
videmment vise à prévoir une exception
pour la pratique de l'année de césure en
précisant bien que celle ci ne pourra
dépasser 12 mois il s'agit bien de
prendre en considération une pratique
courante des établissements
d'enseignement supérieur tels les
grandes écoles et universités qui
permettent ainsi à leurs étudiants
d'enrichir leur expérience en menant à
bien un projet professionnel ou en
effectuant un ou deux stages à
l'étranger cette période représente un
formidable atout pour ces jeunes qui
bénéficient alors d'une grande mobilité
intellectuel et physique du fait de
l'absence de contraintes familiales
merci chers collègues l'amendement 40
rectifier présentée par monsieur barbier
merci
l'amendement 6 et présentée par monsieur
des essarts
tout d'abord monsieur le président je
vais faire un compliment à séance
ce que je mon amendement s'ils se
considèrent
est lié
l'alinéa 62 et puis j'ai des amendements
ensuite qu'ils sont des années à
19 40 ans gisèle comment ça se fait que
je traite le 62 en avant et j'ai compris
cela lorsque j'ai vu que madame procas
ya dans ces amendements traité de
l'alinéa 62 julie quand même la séance
qu'elle travaille quel travail être
capable de voir que mon 62 doit être
avant mon 40 parce que le 62e cité d'un
amendement de l'impro cassia qui
lui-même traite le 14 donc ça formidable
quel talent tout près la séance persie
voyons quel beau travail bon
cela étant dit j'en reviens à mon
amendement il numéro 6 pour l'année à
l'alinéa 62e mais vous l'auriez plus à
fait compris la presse pour la
proposition de loi prévoit de limiter
les stages dans le temps en fixant une
durée maximale de six mois au sein des
mêmes structures
cette disposition est très positive pour
lutter contre les emplois déguisés en
stage ou les ou les faux stage pour
assurer aux entreprises recourant
régulièrement stagiaires une période de
transition de mise en application de la
présente loi il est prévu un délai de
deux ans
pourquoi deux ans bon il semblerait que
un an est suffisant pour pouvoir
s'organiser donc on propose que le délai
de mise en application soit réduit à un
an par cet amendement plutôt que les
deux ans qui sont proposés dans la pro b
qui sont
proposés dans la proposition de loi je
n'ai pas trouvé désolé voilà donc on
veut réduire le temps d'appliquer de
mise en application de deux ans 1 si
chers collègues et enfin l'amendement 74
présenté par madame progression est bien
pour des raisons
tout à fait inverse à celle de messieurs
jean désessard nous nous proposons que
ce soit trois ans tout simplement parce
qu'il s'agit du plj et de maquettes de
formation et comment demander à
un cursus et à des enseignants de
modifier complètement sous prétexte que
on a décidé de modifier la loi qu alors
on and on n'en parlons pas deux ans déjà
cours sans compter que un cycle de
formation dans l'enseignement supérieur
la premier succès 3 ans ça permettrait
tout simplement si la loi est votée en
tant que tel de laisser un petit peu le
temps aux formations de pouvoir
s'ajuster
puisque de toute façon vous prévoyez par
décret des dérogations une liste de
dérogations et je suis sûr qu'au bout de
deux ans il y aura encore d'autres
dérogations qui devront apparaître parce
qu'il y aura des problèmes alors
laissons les enseignants en revoir les
maquettes pédagogiques et des sons un
peu de temps pour mesurer toutes les
dérogations nécessaires à cette loi
qui en sus posera beaucoup à défaut elle
tuera un bon nombre de stages et un bon
nombre de formations merci cher collègue
monsieur rapporteur quel est l'avis de
la commission
sur l'amendement 73
comme nous l'avons déjà expliqué la
commission est opposée l'instauration de
dérogation à cette durée de six mois la
période transitoire de deux ans prévue
par le texte permet de modifier les
formations sur lesquels sept relais
cette règle aurait un impact une fois
encore là pour pédagogique de stages
allant jusqu'à un an n'est pas une
évidence quant aux années de césure qui
par définition ne font pas partie en
tant que tel d'un cursus mais constitue
une interruption de celui ci le stage
n'est peut-être pas la forme juridique
adapté pour l'expérience professionnelle
de plus de six mois on peut penser au
pays et à l'étranger ou bien même un cdd
même si nous a fait part à savoir que
dans certains pays cela pouvait poser
que problème l'autre solution consiste
en la réalisation de deux stages de six
mois ce qui enrichit bien plus le cv de
l'étudiant donc la commission a émis un
avis défavorable sur les 73
sur le quai sur le 43 rectifié de
monsieur barbier donc ne pas imposer une
période de formation au milieu
professionnel en ciment secondaire une
limitation de la durée à six mois cet
amendement souhaite autoriser les pme
paient de plus de six mois j'ai du mal à
imaginer à quelle formation de
l'enseignement secondaire cela pourrait
s'appliquer puisque même dans des cas
extrêmes il n'ya jamais plus de 60 se
mettre semaine pardon de paix ump pour
un cursus de trois ans ce plafond si moi
qui fait déjà partie du droit en vigueur
ne les gênent aucunement de plus il
n'est pas souhaitable que de telles
périodes dures plus de six mois quelle
sera la place pour les enseignants nous
enseignements théoriques délivré dans
l'établissement d'enseignement c'est
donc un avis défavorable
39 rectifié
donc qui souhaitent porter un nom la
durée maximale autorisée pour un stage
où c'est un avis défavorable je sais pas
argumenter à nouveau
d'ailleurs c'est contraire c'est
contraire à l'accord qui a été signé
l'accord national interprofessionnel je
le rappelle à mes collègues par les
partenaires sociaux unanime en 2011
c'est bon a rappelé me semble utile
le
144 cette coordination
le 38 rectifié autoriser des dérogations
à la durée maximale de six mois toujours
pour un stage à la suite d'une
concertation etc les filières concernées
c'est un moment propose de maintenir la
rédaction actuelle du code issu de la
loi le sr tout en la complétant par une
concertation avec les filières
concernées cela ouvrira la voie de
multiples régimes différents fragilisant
l'accord aisance dans ce cas errance
dans son dispositif c'est contraire à
l'esprit de la proposition doit donc la
commission émet un avis défavorable
alors le 127 rectifié est à peu près
identique à celui de monsieur marseille
qui n'a pas été défendu
alors si on comprend l'attention de
l'auteur de l'amendement mois le contenu
de cet amendement en effet il propose
que le document d'évaluation d'un stage
réalisé par un étudiant ne puissent être
conservées au delà de la délivrance de
son diplôme quel est l'intérêt au
contraire c'est lorsque les évaluations
de plusieurs stages différents dans un
organisme ont été réunis par le service
chargé de l'orientation d'un
établissement d'enseignement qu'il sera
possible d'avoir une idée précise de la
qualité de l'accueil des stagiaires dans
cet organisme supprimer progressivement
ses rapports de stage fin contre la
logique de ce processus quant à la
mission de l'enseignant référent et elle
est bien de jouer un rôle de médiateur
est l'interlocuteur du stagiaire et du
tuteur en cas de difficultés nous avons
souhaité que chaque établissement
d'enseignement dans le respect de son
autonomie puisque a précisé la situation
est différente selon les formations et
les métiers je ne crois donc pas que
c'est dans la loi de l'obliger à prendre
contact avec l'organisme d'accueil en
cas de problème la commission a émis un
avis défavorable
le 33 alors c'est interdire des durées
de stage supérieure à celle de la
formation formation délivrée par
l'établissement d'enseignement madame
cohen en confirmant l'institution d'un
volume pédagogique minimale significatif
accompagnons tout stage cette
proposition doit porter un coup sévère à
toutes les structures qui vendent des
conventions de stage ou au diplôme
universitaire dépourvus de contenu
pédagogique je ne pense donc pas qu'il
soit nécessaire d'aller plus loin c'est
un avis défavorable
9,75 rectifié alors autorisé des stages
de 12 mois pour les années de césure
nous avons déjà expliqué et réexpliqué
je ne suis pas favorable à cette mesure
un stage de douze mois réalisée par
l'étudiant en cours de master qui a déjà
un haut niveau de qualification peut
éviter l'entreprise d'embaucher un
salarié quant à la définition et la
régulation de l'année de césure qui a il
est vrai que du à développement rapide
ces dernières années je crois que le
ministère est actuellement en train de
travailler sur ce sujet peut-être que
madame la ministre pourra nous apporter
quelques précisions en tout état de
cause la commission a émis un avis
défavorable sur cet amendement
c'est un amendement de conséquence donc
cet avis défavorable bien sûr
alors le 6 cl 74 il y aura un avis
défavorable pour les deux puisque ce
monsieur dés et soeur veut descendent un
nom celui de madame progression se monte
à 3 ans nous suggérons de rester à deux
ans donc avis défavorable pour les deux
merci monsieur rapporteur manama
ministre quel est l'avis du gouvernement
merci monsieur président alors sur
l'amendement numéro 73
tout d'abord je voudrais rappeler que
l'interdiction des stages de plus de six
mois est une disposition issue d'un
accord entre les partenaires sociaux
c'est la nuit du 16 juin 2013 qui 2011
par donc été repris par la loi cherpion
du 28 juillet 2011 malheureusement la
loi du 28 juillet 2011 comme j'avais dit
en préambule avait prévu des exceptions
très large cette règle et ses exceptions
avait vidé la loi de son contenu parce
que les dérogations étaient tellement
large que finalement la loi ne
s'appliquait quasiment plus
ces exceptions concernés notamment les
stagiaires qui interrompent
momentanément leur formation afin
d'exercer des activités visant
exclusivement l'acquisition de
compétences en liaison que cette
formation et concerner aussi les stages
qui sont prévus dans le cadre d'un
cursus pluriannuel de l'enseignement
supérieur bref on avait une définition
est extrêmement large et la ppl
proposons de supprimer ces exceptions
pour donner toute sa portée à
l'interdiction des stages de plus de six
mois en maintenant cependant une
exception temporaire cela a été dit pour
des formations nécessitant une
réingénierie labo ration de nouvelles
maquettes sont les 14 formations prévues
et vu en concertation avec le ministère
des affaires sociales et de la santé les
maquettes peuvent être modifiées pour
2015 donc on pourra appliquer la loi à
la rentrée de 2016 puisque les états
généraux de ceux de l'action sociale ne
sont encore en cours par ailleurs nous
avons l'accord de la de l'association
qui réunit l'équivalent de la cpu si
vous voulez pour les rts pour toutes les
formations des travailleurs sociaux qui
nous a dit qu en deux ans il était
capable de revoir ses maquettes de
formation en non ne sont pas capables
trois ans c'est trop et se sont engagés
sur deux ans c'est pourquoi encore une
fois nous n'avons pas fait une moyenne
entre 3 ans et un an mais c'est
simplement le résultat de la
concertation qui amène finalement à
cette moyenne donc pour ces raisons
l'amendement
l'amendement 73 reçoit un avis
défavorable du gouvernement
ensuite il y à l'amendement
43,2 me proposées par monsieur présentée
par monsieur bart à monsieur le sénateur
barbier et qui vise à exclure les pf mp
de l'obligation de limites du stage à
six mois il s'avère que nous sommes
enseigner auprès de la dgesco et qu'il
n'y a aucune formation prévue par les
lycées professionnels qu'ils soient
supérieures à six mois le la répartition
la plus courante ces six semaines plus
suisse mène plus suisse mène et donc
comme il n'y a pas a priori de formation
de petits mois consécutif de fait nous
nous avons vraiment demandé à la dgesco
de chercher dans toutes les formations
et n'ont pas trouvé de fait votre
amendement est sans objet pour ces
raisons nous émettons un avis
défavorable
ensuite il ya l'amendement numéro 39
présentée par monsieur barbier
et qui parle de qui évoque l'année de
césure j'ai peut-être répondre aux deux
amendements en même temps et a su de
madame de brocas ya l'année de césure
effectivement est proposée par certains
établissements le plus souvent c'est une
interruption volontaire des études par
un étudiant validé par l'établissement
qui prend l engagement d'accepter
l'étudiant lors de sa reprise d'études
le cden césure elle peut donner lieu à
des expériences multiples un tour du
monde un engagement humanitaire ou
associatifs nice ou une expérience
professionnelle l'année de césure n'est
pas interdite n'est pas empêché par
cette loi mais l'expérience
professionnelle réalisée dans ce cas
devra s'effectuer autrement que sous la
forme d'un stage de plus de six mois ça
peut être effectivement deux stages de
six mois dans deux entreprises
différentes ou deux organismes
différents mais ça peut être aussi le
recours au travail de droit commun ça
peut être aussi avait eu ça peut être
aussi
un statut d'emploi civique bref on a
plusieurs statues qui peuvent
très utilement se substituer à celui de
stage qui n'était pas vraiment adapté
puisqu'il n'ya pas de formation de
formation qui l'accompagnent et pour ces
raisons vos deux amendements qui porte
sur ce même point sont rejetés par le
gouvernement
ensuite nous avons l'amendement
légistique de monsieur godefroy du
rapporteur qui bien entendu fait l'objet
d'un avis favorable
ensuite nous avons l'amendement numéro
et qui compte favorable je crois mais
non pardon ah non
pardon alors excusez moi non j'avais cru
comprendre que vous aviez déjà dit
défavorable mais non j'étais falloir
bosser même procas yak évoqué l'année de
césure 227,8 d'accord voilà donc sur
l'amendement numéro 38 j'en ai déjà
parlé en fait ça concerne
voilà ça concerne en particulier les
formations sociales le secteur social et
médico-social qui a fait l'objet d'une
concertation avec le ministère et
l'établissement concerné dont une à four
hills donc pour les mêmes raisons avis
défavorable ensuite
il ya l'amendement
127 voilà
alors là j'avoue que la procédure qui
est proposé pour l'évaluation de qualité
des stages me paraît excessivement
détaillé complexe pour être intégré dans
la loi dans la loi nous avons indiqué
dans la loi du 22 juillet 2013 son
enseignement supérieur et recherche il y
avait sept
modalités si j'ai bonne mémoire qui
concernait les stages d'enseignement
supérieur et qui prévoyait effectivement
qu'il fallait une évaluation qualitative
et qu'ils ont dans les termes soit soit
fixée en particulier par les
responsables de formation et à la
procédure qui est proposé dans
l'amendement me paraît bien trop
détaillée pour être du niveau de la loi
donc je pense qu'il faut aussi les à
faire confiance aux établissements pour
produire leurs propres modalités sachant
que la loi donne l'orientation de la
qualité donc pour cette raison avis
défavorable ensuite il y avait
l'amendement numéro 33 proposé par
madame cohen sur les limites de la durée
du stage à la durée du volume 2 de
formation là nous avons déjà de fait
répondu en mettant un volume de
formation minimum de 200 heures et qui
nous prémunit contre les risques
de deux stages
apparemment alléchant et de fait
quasiment frauduleux
ensuite l'amendement numéro 75 donc j'ai
répondu c'est celui là en fait il ya un
avis défavorable et qui concerne l'année
de césure qui encore une fois n'est pas
menacée mais qui peut utiliser bien
d'autres dispositifs et dont deux stages
dans deux endroits différents
ensuite l'amendement numéro 40 de
monsieur barbier j'ai déjà répondu
puisque l'amendement de conséquence du
meuble de l'abondement numéro 39 pour
lequel le gouvernement donné un avis
défavorable
l'amendement au numéro 6 de monsieur
désessard là j'ai répondu également
puisque nous sommes entre le 1 et ont
demandé le 3 ans demandés et que de fait
les organismes responsables de ces
formations eux mêmes non nous ont donné
leur accord sur la durée de deux ans
pour refaire les maquettes de formation
ensuite l'amendement 114 donc voilà j'ai
répondu donc ces avis défavorable
et c'est tout
absolument
alors nous revenons sur l'amendement 73
pas de demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter veuille
bien levé la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre veut bien
levé la main
l'amendement n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 43 rectifié pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter veut bien levé la
main
merci que ceux qui sont contre veut bien
levé la main
l'amendement n'est pas adopté la montre
on peut rectifier pas d'explications de
vote même vote même bottes l'amendement
140 capte pas de demandes d'explications
de vote que ceux qui souhaitent adopter
veut bien levé la main
merci opposition il est adopté
l'amendement 38 rectifié
explications de vote ma profession
je les dis déjà
engagé j'ai du mal à comprendre que le
gouvernement ne veuille pas engager des
concertations avec les filiales des
filières excusez-moi des filières
concernées on est toujours en train de
prôner le dialogue social se dire que
dans un certain nombre de cas on peut
quand même allés discuter et voir avec
les filières et les branches me paraît
totalement contradictoire avec la
politique qui est soi-disant celles
menées depuis deux ans
alors je suis désolé mais en fait ils
tombent
voilà ça a quand même permis à l'impro
cachette s'exprimer mais en réalité le
le 38 rectifier le 127 rectifié tombe
voilà du fait du 144 et nous passons
donc aux 33 rectifié pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter veuille bien levé la
main merci avis contraire
l'amendement n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 75 rectifié pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter veuille bien levé la
main
merci que ceux qui sont contre veut bien
levé la main l'amendement n'est pas
adopté de 40 rectifié même vol même vote
le 6
il est retiré
merci et le 74
maintenu
pas de demande d'explications que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter va bien levé la
main merci avis contraire
l'amendement n'est pas adopté
alors nous avons 17 amendements qui font
l'objet d'une discussion commune nous
commençons par le 61 rectifié bill je
passe la parole à charles revêt oui
merci monsieur le président le ministre
le principe d'une obligation
gratification bénéfice des étudiants
pour les stages d'une durée supérieure à
deux mois ne souffre pas en lui-même de
critiques malgré les difficultés
évidentes qu'il soulève dans son
application dans norbourg eux dans de
nombreux secteurs services de l'état
collectivités territoriales secteur de
santé et autres similaires élargir à
tous les élèves de l'enseignement
professionnel soit environ un million
d'élèves non 150000 l'enseignement et
l'école inscrits en formation de ces
apps et de bac professionnel
l'obligation gratification est
dissuasive pour les maîtres de stage un
jeune de quinze ans et ap ne peut être
mis sur le même plan qu'un étudiant en
termes d'autonomie d'appréhension des
choses et d'apport à l'organisme
d'accueil
certaines enseignes pour l'accueil
d'étudiants ont déjà pour politique de
refuser tout stage de plus de huit
semaines comment imaginer que les
services de l'état les collectivités
intérieur territoriales les écoles les
crèches le secteur sanitaire et social
on y reviendra en général gratifieront
des élèves de cp au bac professionnel
pour les enseignes les élèves de
l'enseignement professionnel la
gratification de rester une faculté mais
ne peut constituer d'obligations
merci chers collègues et l'amendement 14
et présenté par madame cohen oui
monsieur le président avec votre accord
je défendrai conjointement les
amendements 14 et 16 qui portent tous
deux sur la gratification des stagiaires
alors que la législation actuellement en
vigueur prévoit que les stages ou droit
au versement d'une ti fication si leur
durée supérieure à deux mois la présente
proposition de loi intègre une évolution
certaine bien que jugée insuffisante par
les collectifs représentant les
stagiaires en effet elle précise que
cette gratification est due au stagiaire
à compter du premier jour du premier
mois de la période de stage de formation
en milieu professionnel
je les dis elle est positive mais elle
est insuffisante les employeurs les
moins honnêtes trouveront des moyens de
contournement comme la signature de
conventions de stage de deux mois - un
jour bien entendu il ne s'agit pas
d'assimiler stages et contrats de
travail même s'il faut admettre que les
stagiaires accomplissent des missions
qui profite tout de même aux entreprises
au groupe crc nous sommes convaincus que
la gratification des stages y compris de
courte durée génère deux avantages
certains tout d'abord les stagiaires
pourront bénéficier d'une gratification
dans tous les cas ce qui bien évidemment
est une mesure importante pour eux même
si cette gratification est insuffisante
mais cette mesure permettra également de
limiter singulièrement les abus les
techniques de contournement dont j'ai
fait mention qui ne manqueront pas
d'exposé de bain quant à l'amendement
numéro 16 il a pour sa part vocation à
porter le seuil minimum minimal de la
gratification à une somme équivalente à
50 % du smic là encore cette proposition
est portée par les représentants des
étudiants et des stagiaires qui savent
mieux que quiconque les difficultés
financières que rencontrent ces mêmes
stagiaires particulièrement lorsque ces
derniers n'habite plus chez leurs
parents c'est pourquoi à l'image de nos
collègues du groupe gdr front de gauche
à l'assemblée nationale
nous sommes convaincus de l'importance
de ces amendements pour enrichir cette
proposition de loi
donc nous faisons d'amendements numéro
15 peut-être un poème dans l'ancien
le 15 il est il est retiré
l'amendement 145 et présentée par
monsieur le rapporteur pour la
commission des affaires sociales
madame ann hui cet amendement abaisse
l'obligation de gratification des stages
pour l'enseignement supérieur à tous
ceux d'entre eux deux plus de deux mois
tout en maintenant la durée minimale de
deux mois pour les périodes de formation
en milieu professionnel de
l'enseignement secondaire
n'entendons de trop nombreuses car les
entreprises vont se succéder des sages
de huit semaines pour ne pas avoir à
verser de gratification il est proposé
de mettre un terme à de tels
contournement de la législation qui
constituent des abus si on peut estimer
qu'un stage de découverte d'un mois le
dow perd lui a tellement donné lieu à
une ratification après un mois passé
dans l'organisme d'accueil un étudiant
de l'enseignement supérieur est sans nul
doute en mesure de participer utilement
à l'activité de celui ci
c'est le sens de l'amendement que
violeur de vous présenter
merci l'amendement car entre eux deux
quatre rectifiée présentée par monsieur
barbier
tendu
q de stagiaires dans la détermination du
montant de la gratification
comme en matière de contrats
d'apprentissage de décret prévu par
l'article 112 11 du code de l'éducation
devenu
124,6 fixerait une grille permettant de
faire varier la gratification selon l'
année d'études en cours un tel
amendement permettrait notamment de
mieux valoriser les stages effectués en
fin d'études alors que les stagiaires
exécutent des tâches qui s'approche de
celle des salariés
merci chers collègues l'amendement
numéro 11 est présentée par monsieur
lessard
je pense que cet amendement doit voir
des similitudes avec celui que qu'a
présenté le rapporteur il concerne la
gratification des stagiaires et la
période
d'indemnisation ou plutôt quand commence
indemnisation puisque la législation
actuelle prévoit que tout stage d'une
durée minimale de deux mois consécutifs
ouvre droit à une gratification
cette durée avaient été abaissés il ya
quelques années mais on considère
qu'elle est encore trop longue
en effet on a constaté la multiplication
des stages d'une durée de 1 mois et 29
jours durée qui empêche l'ouverture
droit à la gratification cet amendement
vise donc à ramener cette durée minimale
de 2 mois à 4 semaines cette durée ne
semble équilibrée elle permet de lutter
plus efficacement contre les entreprises
qui jouent avec les effets de seuil pour
ne pas rémunérer leurs stagiaires elle
permet de maintenir hors de l'obligation
de rémunération des stages de découverte
de deux ou trois semaines à ce propos
nous avons été interpellé mais je crois
que c'est un débat qui viendra plus tard
par les maisons familiales au sujet de
la rémunération de leurs stagiaires ces
maisons accueillent en effet des jeunes
pré bac dès la quatrième qui alterne
périodes scolaires et périodes de stages
tout au long de l'année pour leur faire
découvrir les métiers d'agriculture de
commerce ont encore du tourisme leur
durée de stage dépasse bien entendu le
seuil actuel de moi la présente
proposition de loi prévoit que les
nouvelles dispositions s'appliqueront
aussi bien aux étudiants qu'aux
scolaires c'est la rémunération d'un
stagiaire de supérieur qui contribue à
l'activité économique de sa structure
d'accueil est justifié on peut
s'interroger sur la pertinence de
rémunérer des en stage de découverte
donc la question suivante les maisons
familiales et rurales seront elles
tenues de rémunérer ces jeunes
stagiaires c'est une question qui a été
posée avant le repas nous devions
recevoir un amendement mais certainement
qui va être il est là donc il a été
remis à mais j'ai pas merci comment
vous avez veillé à ce qu'il soit remis
et donc je vais en bénéficier de votre
vigilance 1
et donc nous en débattrons plus tard en
tout cas notre amendement propose que la
période de rémunération commence à
partir d'un mois de stage
merci chers collègues l'amendement 116
rectifier il est défendu
l'amendement
146 présentée par monsieur le rapporteur
au nom de la commission des affaires
sociales chez le président de la
ministre cet amendement à une petite
histoire je vais être contraint de vous
raconter quelques instants
en 2006 j'avais déposé un amendement
tendant à porter la gratification à 50 %
du smic en 2006 un enthousiasme dans
l'opposition qui trouve parfois ses
limites dans la gestion ceci étant c'est
à cet amendement est repris je crois
dans une certaine madame cohen donc j'ai
essayé de réfléchir parce que il me
semble ce malgré tout que les stagiaires
doivent être traitées je dirais de d'une
façon très convenable moi je suis très
sensible au discours que l'on peut
entendre temps du président de la
république que d'un certain nombre donc
deux responsables concernant notre
jeunesse et j'y adhère j'y adhère
pleinement parce que je crois que nous
avons une belle jeunesse mais qu'il faut
lui donner des signes d'encouragement
elle en a bien besoin
donc là ce que je vous propose c'est de
supprimer toute référence au smic parce
que c'est une référence qui pourrait
avoir une référence salariale ça
pourrait être ambigu et donc je vous
propose
porter la gratification qui est
aujourd'hui à 12 5% du plafond de la
sécurité sociale soit 436 euros 0,5 à
15% de ce plafond soit 523 20,6 euros ce
qui ferait une augmentation de la
gratification mensuelle pour un
stagiaire mais c'est le volume minimal
c'est à dire donc d'environ 90 euros
sachant qu'il y a des entreprises qui
gratifie les stages d'une façon beaucoup
plus importante que ce plafond minimal
de rémunération de gratification et je
crois que cela encore ceux qui ont cette
gratification minimales sont bien
souvent ce sont eux qui sont les plus
défavorisés que depuis difficultés à
trouver des stages dont je pense que je
serai une décision de justice sociale
l'amendement 57 rectifié brice est
présentée par monsieur oui merci
monsieur le président je vais simplement
vire le texte et non pas tous l'objet en
fait ils proposent remplacer les allées
les alinéas 21 et 22 cet article par
trois jeunes et à assurer 10 g sont
ajoutés deux alinéas ainsi rédigés donc
le premier le premier alinéa ne
s'applique pas aux élèves et étudiants
préparant des diplômes spécifiques au
secteur sanitaire social et médico
social
ensuite la gratification mentionné au
premier alinéa est due au stagiaire à
compter du premier jour du premier mois
de la période du sein d'autres
formations milieu professionnel j'aurais
peut-être ce président puisque j'ai
quand même
tu es bref ajouter un mot bien entendu
on serait tous d'accord pour rémunérer
et les jeunes qui font des stages bons
mais qu'est ce qui compte qu'est-ce qui
est le plus important c'est que le jeune
puisse faire son sale et qui est pas des
conditions qui font que il est des
difficultés à trouver des stages et
c'est souvent un petit peu l'ambiguïté
c'est à dire que beaucoup de jeunes ont
du mal des entreprises parce que les
jeunes il faut bien le fort mais il faut
bien qu'il y ait un formateur dans
l'entreprise pour l'aider et autres et
quelque part
il ya des interrogations qui se font en
dix ans mais le temps qu'on consacre à
former le jeune et c'est très bien eh
bien on ne l'a pas pour autre chose et
donc quelque part il ya une forme de
compensation donc je répète on voudrait
tous que tous les jeunes qui vont faire
des stalles puissent être rémunérés mais
à condition que ce soit pas dissuasif et
que ce pas finalement contraire à
l'intérêt du jeune
merci chers collègues l'amendement 16 a
été présenté l'amendement 82 et présenté
par alain professeurs
oui cet amendement est simple il fixe il
permet il impose
que tout stagiaires soient payés pour la
durée du mois quel que soit le nombre de
jours dans le mois et qu'il y ait ou pas
des jours fériés sa jeune j'en ai parlé
en commission des affaires sociales je
ne citerai pas l'organisme très proche
qui pratiquent mais avec une belle
lettre juridique expliquant que pour
l'instant quand par exemple nous sommes
au mois de mai et qu on va pas
travailler le 2 mai et bien le 2 mai
n'étant pas un jour férié l'entreprise
est fermée mais on déduit une journée
non travaillée de ses 435 euros
avec une belle est juridique appuyé sur
tous les articles du code du travail
mais tellement bien rangé depuis que
j'attendais d'en parler je n'ai pas
retrouvé pour vous la présenter mais
c'est l'objectif l'objectif est bien
qu'on ne tombe pas en dessous de la
rémunération imposées
et est minimale
merci chers collègues on à l'amendement
96 qui présentait dans le chai savary
et toujours dans le cadre des
rémunérations à 1 fixé dans 436 euros
actuellement
certains établissements d'accueil
accorde une gratification plus important
ce qui est maire mais dans ce cas là ils
doivent établir une feuille de paye et
verser des cotisations sociales donc il
faudrait supprimer ce coût
supplémentaire afin d'inciter d'autres
entreprises à dépasser ce plafond de 436
euros dès l'instant où elles sont bien
sûr volontaire
c'est ce qui nous fait vous proposer des
modifications dans le cadre de la linea
merci l'amendement 17 et présentée par
monsieur le scouarnec
merci monsieur le président la ministre
mes chers collègues avec cet amendement
nous poursuivons dans la logique notre
amendement précédent qui tend à
améliorer la gratification des
stagiaires en effet cet amendement
numéro 10 est propos de préciser que
cette gratification soit progressive en
fonction de deux éléments essentiels la
durée des stages et le niveau d'études
des stagiaires on peut légitimement
supposer qu'un stagiaire de master sera
plus efficace aura des compétences
accrues et sera bien plus performant
dans l'entreprise qu'un stagiaire de
niveau licence il semble également
souhaitable que les stades les plus
longs soient les mieux rémunérés pour
les mêmes raisons que précédemment à
savoir que plus le stage est long plus
le stagiaire est efficace dans
l'entreprise il s'agit également d'une
forme de responsabilisation des
employeurs afin qu'ils évitent le
recrutement permanent de stagiaire au
sein de leur entreprise afin de rendre
opérant ces mesures nous proposons que
cette mesure fasse l'objet d'un décret
dont nous proposons qu'ils soient
élaborés en lien avec les organisations
syndicales et les associations
représentatives des étudiants pour la 6
merci chers collègues deux amendements
identiques que l'amendement 50 et
présenté par madame ferrand merci
monsieur le président est d'ailleurs cet
amendement 50 est tout à fait
complémentaire avec 49 qui viendra un
petit peu plus tard et dans cet
amendement nous souhaitions inséré un
alinéa ainsi rédigé le présent article
n'est pas applicable aux périodes de
formation en milieu professionnel ou aux
stages réalisés dans le cadre des
enseignements visées à l'article 8 113 9
du code rural et de la pêche
madame la ministre vous et moi n'avons
pas la même lecture
du code rural est en tout cas de cet
article parce que autant dans le dans
l'article en question on parle bien du
rythme approprié ou temps dans
l'amendement que vous nous avez proposé
sur talent je ne me retrouve pas alors
sans doute que c'est l'heure tardive
mais je ne retrouve pas
nécessaire clarté qui serait favorable à
ma compréhension et j'avoue que par delà
tout cela vous nous proposez un décret
pour compléter la situation donc très
sincèrement
alors que j'avais cru comprendre que
vous étiez très attentive à nos
remarques concernant le rythme approprié
et la nécessaire
comment vous dire
intervention sur ce qui touche les
maisons familiales et le
parcours pédagogique qui ne peut pas se
faire s'il n'y a pas de stage je ne vous
cache pas que aux troubles et tout et
tout plus fort alors tout simplement mon
but voilà ce décret moi ça ne me semble
pas tout à fait raisonnable alors je
vous fais une proposition très simple
que madame la ministre adopter tout à
l'heure on amendement 49 il est très
simple il dit ceci il exclut tout
simplement l'enseignement agricole du
dispositif d'encadrement des stages que
vous nous proposez ce soir votre cadre
est trop rigide vous ne prenez pas en
compte les spécificités des uns et des
autres et l'enseignement agricole en est
un particulier tes chers collègues
l'amendement 62 rectifié terre est
présenté par le président il a été
clairement défendu par l'amfar à fait
utile identique vous l'avez souligné
donc est défendu merci l'amendement 95
et présenté par alain bolhy r
oui il s'agit il s'agit du d'étendre aux
étudiants du secteur sanitaire et social
et médico-social les dispositions
applicables aux étudiants des
professions paramédicales en matière de
non gratification des stages en effet
dans les deux cas les stages conditions
d'accès à la profession et sont souvent
difficiles à trouver il faut donc éviter
toute contrainte qui viendrait limiter
effectivement le recours aux stages
légaliser le traitement est parée par
ailleurs souhaitable pour ces
professions très proche par nature
chers collègues enfin le 150 et présenté
par madame la ministre pour le
gouvernement
le cent cinquante ans
alors j'ai essayé de vous expliquer cet
amendement qui
moi aussi à vrai dire qu'ils étaient
radi qui a été rédigée en jeu présente
qui était rédigé en concertation avec le
ministère de l'agriculture et en
concertation comme l'ensemble des
dispositions que j'ai présentées je le
dis au passage parce que tout à l'heure
comme l'amendement est tombé j'ai pas pu
vous répondre tout ce que nous avons
proposé a été fait en concertation pas
seulement les ministères mais également
avec les acteurs concernés donc le
musicien d'agriculture s'est concerté
avec
les maisons familiales rurales qui leur
ont dit que elle pouvait indemnisés mais
pas à partir de deux mois de demande de
deux stages et qu'elle souhaitait un
passage notamment de deux à trois mois
comme nous considérons cette négociation
s'est fait un peu rapidement nous
préférons renvoyer un décret qui
autorise du coup d'allonger d'allonger
la durée la période de stage non
indemnisés pour les mfr c'est ce qu'ont
dit les mfr missa d'agriculture mais
nous préférons nous donner le temps du
décret pour pouvoir affiner la
proposition simplement en acceptant cet
amendement vous accepter le fait qu'il y
aura un régime spécifique pour les mfr
négocié par décret et en concertation
avec tm fr parce que sur le une ou deux
journées j'estime que la concertation a
dû être même un peu comment dire rapide
de la part du ministère de l'agriculture
bon la période ne se prêtait pas non
plus
ne se produire absolument
mais oui mais il faut être solidaire
sinon on n'est pas efficace donc voilà
donc nous nous préférons renvoyer un
décret rond sachant que est inscrit tout
de même dans la loi grâce à cet
amendement le principe d'un mode de un
mode différent
et plus favorable de gratification pour
les stagiaires dans les maisons
familiales rurales
merci madame la ministre donc nous
arrivons à l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
allons-y l'amendement 61 rectifié donc
de monsieur
monsieur roger alors contrairement à ce
que certains peuvent penser cette
obligation il s'agit donc de supprimer
l'obligation de gratification pour les
périodes de formation en milieu
professionnel
contrairement à ce que certains peuvent
penser cette obligation figure déjà dans
le droit actuel elles sont gommées
ignorer sinon consciemment enfreinte est
ce une raison pour la faire disparaître
je ne le crois pas car on peut partir du
principe que tout jeunes présents au
stage dans un organisme depuis au moins
deux mois contribuer à son activité et a
dépassé le stade de l'acquisition des
principes de base surtout les pf mpf est
de plus de deux mois sont très rares y
compris dans le secteur du travail
social ainsi le cep petite enfance
comprend douze semaines de pfm paix sur
deux ans soit six semaines par an ce qui
n'entraîne pas de gratification
obligatoire donc ceci étant rappelé la
commission émet un avis défavorable
sur l'amendement 14 de madame cohen
rangs de la gratification obligatoire
des premiers jours de stage alors je
comprends tout à fait l'intention des
auteurs de l'amendement et j'aimerais
qu'il soit possible de voir des
satisfactions néanmoins cela aurait pour
effet de causer de grandes difficultés
pour trouver des stages un certain
niveau d'études en particulier en
licence surtout cela aura un impact très
important dans l'enseignement secondaire
où la plupart des périodes de formation
en milieu professionnel dure quelques
semaines ou à peine plus d'un mois s'il
fallait que les élèves qui dans ce cas
sont en phase de découverte et
d'apprentissage des principes de base
d'un métier touche une gratification
l'offre de pfm pc tahrir est
dangereusement s'il accepte
j'invite les auteurs de cet amendement à
se rallier à ce livre je présente
l'amendement 145 dont nous aurons à
débattre tout à l'heure donc cet
amendement la commission et bien l'avis
défavorable
l'amendement 15
amendement identique à l'amendement
précédent se retirer
l'amendement 145 écoutez c'est c'est le
mien je lui ai déjà défendu il a fait
l'objet d'un avis favorable de la
commission
ensuite l'article 44
l'amendement 44 de monsieur barbier
supprimer l'obligation de ratification
par les périodes de formation en milieu
professionnel de plus de deux mois alors
c'est le même objet commandement 61 j'ai
déjà répondu donc c'est un avis
défavorable
l'amendement 11 rangs de la
gratification obligatoire monsieur dés
et soeurs pour les stages ou peur de
formation en milieu professionnel depuis
quatre semaines ici encore si je partage
la volonté des auteurs de cet amendement
il me semble que son chant est trop
large puisqu'il inclut également les
périodes de formation en milieu
professionnel de l'enseignement
secondaire or il ne me semble pas
souhaitable d'un site une gratification
pour les fmp de plus de quatre semaines
ce qui toucherait de très nombreux bacs
pros et c'est ap en revanche pour les
stages d'enseignement supérieur je suis
convaincu que vous aurez à coeur de
bougeoirs à l'amendement 145 que j'ai
déposé cet amendement une rose a reçu un
avis de retrait la part de la commission
l'amendement 116 monsieur barbier faire
varier la gratification en fonction du
niveau d'études du stagiaire alors je ne
suis pas favorable à une telle solution
qui aurait à mon avis plus d'effets
néfastes que d'effets positifs cela
aboutira t-il à la bc la gratification
des moins qualifiés a rapproché
rapprochait celle des plus qualifiés du
smic et donc à les assimiler à des
salariés dans les faits de nombreux
organismes font varier la gratification
proposés aux stagiaires sont les
missions offertes et donc le niveau de
qualification
c'est une pratique légitime qui relève
de chaque employeur ce n'est pas la voix
de fixer un principe si général qui
n'existe d'ailleurs pas pour les
salariés donc la commission a demandé le
retrait de 7,6 non avis défavorable
à l'amendement 146 c'est
c'est voilà la commission a émis un avis
favorable
ensuite l'amendement 57 exclure de
l'obligation de gratification des stages
réalisés dans le cadre de formation dans
le secteur sanitaire social ou
médico-social alors le choix inverse a
été fait l'an dernier dans la loi us air
qui a rendu universelle cette
gratification quel que soit l'organisme
d'accueil c'est une question de justice
et d'équité entre tous les étudiants
sans nier les obstacles que cette
évolution pu parfois rencontrer le
gouvernement s'est engagé à soutenir les
organismes qui rencontreraient des
difficultés par la mise en place d'un
fonds spécifique chargé d'apporter un
soutien financier
je pense que madame le ministre pourra
vous apporter des précisions l'avis de
la commission est défavorable
le 57 rectifié beast monsieur hve
c'est bien de le faire c'est celui-là
c'est parce que je sais maintenant c'est
le 16 mai pardon
mais non mais non
alors le bon bah voilà l'amendement saez
nam cohen fixer le montant minimal de
gratification 50 % du smic je crois que
l'expliqué tout à l'heure et la
commission émis un avis de retraite
sinon défavorable
le 82ème pro cassis à prévert que le
montant de la gratification versée ne
varient pas selon le nombre de jours
ouvrés
est ce à dire qu'il faudrait qu'à
gratification reste fixe même si le
stagiaire bénéficie au même titre que
les salariés des jours fériés ou d'un
pont question cette mesure peut sembler
d'ordre réglementaire néanmois la
commission a émis un avis favorable pour
cet amendement qui rappelle l'existence
de comportements peu correct de la part
de certains employeurs afin que le
gouvernement puisse préciser comment
s'applique la réglementation sur ce
point parce que je confirme les propos
mêmes provocations nous avons été
alertés par certains organismes qui
déduisent les jours de pont en disant
vous ne travaillez pas donc on va vous
enlever
à 38 ou 1,25
est-ce que c'est bien nécessaire de
pénaliser ainsi les jeunes stagiaires
ont leur enlevant le 12 ou 15 euros ces
prothèses qui est un pont un jour non
travaillé donc avis favorable de la
commission
l'amendement 96
l'élargissement des exonérations de
cotisations sociales dont bénéficient la
gratification versée hausse aux
stagiaires aujourd'hui la gratification
et exonérations sociales lorsqu'elle est
au minimum légal soit 12 5% du plafond
de la sécurité sociale
je ne suis pas certain que la solution
pour les employés que je suis pas c'est
que la solution pour que les enfants
actuels de gratifier davantage les
stagiaires soit de leur offrir une
exonération supplémentaire
est ce vraiment le seul signal auxquels
ils répondent à l'heure où les comptes
sociaux sont en situation très
préoccupante
doit-on toucher à cette modalité certes
anecdotique de financement de la
protection je ne crois pas c'est un avis
défavorable
le progressivité madame cohen de la
gratification des stagiaires sont la
durée du stage et le niveau d'études du
stagiaire alors là je ne suis pas
favorable à une telle mesure qui
s'inspire de la législation concernant
les apprentis les stages ne peuvent pas
dépasser six mois envisage-t-on de faire
évoluer chaque mois la gratification il
me semble que ce serait source de
complexité pour les organismes d'accueil
et qu'au final ça se retournerait contre
les stagiaires il est facile d'imaginer
les comportements qu'adopteront de
nombreuses entreprises elles arrêteront
tout simplement d'organiser des stages
longs de même fixé la gratification
selon le niveau d'études n'est pas dans
l'intérêt des moins qualifiés en
particulier des étudiants issus de
filières professionnelles du premier si
l'enseignement supérieur un an qu'il
perçoit apporter plus à l'activité de
l'entreprise qu'un stagiaire de master
qui la découvrent voilà pourquoi je
demanderai leur triste avis de la
commission sinon défavorable
l'amendement 50 de madame sera exonérée
de l'obligation de gratification les
périodes de formation en milieu
professionnel
des maisons familiales rurales je pense
que la réponse a été apportée je ne vais
pas assister puisque même la ministre
précisera
non nous avons prévu de solliciter
l'avis du gouvernement
il me semble que la réponse a déjà été
apportées l'amendement de monsieur revêt
même objet est donc la même chose le 95
de madame pro cassia exclure de
l'obligation de gratification des stages
réalisés dans le cadre des formations
dans le secteur sanitaire social
médico-social le choix inverse a été
fait l'an dernier dans le loir-et-cher
qui a rendu universal cette
gratification quel que soit l'organisme
d'accueil donc c'est un avis défavorable
et ensuite le l'amendement 150 du
gouvernement et la commission ne s'est
pas réunie pour pas qu'on sait par
contre j'y suis personnellement
favorable
merci monsieur rapporteur
madame la ministre quel est l'avis du
gouvernement
le président
on commence par l'amendement numéro 61
ans d'abord je serai repréciser
puisqu'on on a l'impression quand vous
présentez ces amendements que
cette proposition de loi
propose pour la première fois de
légiférer sur les stages qui sont qui
s'accomplissent dans le cadre des lycées
professionnels
non tous les dispositifs du site hâtif
précédent concernés déjà l'enseignement
secondaire et donc l'enseignement
professionnel dont donc vous non 1 mais
on pouvait comprendre dans d'autres
interventions que c'était quelque chose
de nouveau avec lequel on n'est pas
d'accord ou alors en profiter de
l'opportunité de cette proposition de
loi pour revenir sur quelque chose sur
lequel j'avais et légiférer c'est pas
bien clair dont je voulais leur préciser
nous re coded pions en réalité mais à
droit constant et il n'y a pas de
nouveauté de ce point de vue là donc
pour les raisons qu'on était bien
explicités par
le rapporteur eux mêmes avis donc avis
défavorable pour l'amendement numéro 61
pour l'amendement numéro 14 pour des
raisons là aussi explicite et par le
rapporteur avis défavorable du
gouvernement
l'amendement numéro 15 a été retiré
l'amendement numéro 145
alors voilà c'est c'est celui présenté
par le rapporteur alors l'esprit de la
loi demandant pour le gouvernement était
un peu différent c'est à dire que nous
avons préféré élargir à des formations
qui pour l'instant ne dispensait pas de
gratification
de d'élargir à ces formations le fait de
dispenser des gratifications voeux à
l'ensemble des stagiaires pour le dire
plus clairement on a préféré mettre
l'ensemble des stagiaires sur un même
niveau et d'équité en prenant compte les
spécificités on y reviendra des
formations sociales et des maisons
familiales rurales mais nous avons
préféré faire ça ce qui représente déjà
un effort financier assez important
d'autant que pour les formations les
travailleurs sociaux il ya un fonds
spécifique dédiée qui permettra de faire
la transition donc c'est l'état qui ont
qui a dédié une somme qui n'était pas
prévu budgétairement pour pour cela donc
nous avons préféré améliorer la
situation générale des stagiaires c'est
ainsi que la loi qui a été votée le 22
juillet 2013 a pour la première fois
demandé aux à l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales de verser
une gratification à leurs stagiaires ce
n'était pas le cas auparavant seules les
administrations d'état y étaient
assujettis donc nous étions plutôt dans
cette démarche nous sommes même
résolument dans cette démarche plutôt
que dans le même temps a ajouté un
changement un changement de deux
curseurs tel que celui que vous proposez
et qui est d'abaisser un mois de stage
obligations gratification pour les
stagiaires de l'enseignement supérieur
de plus il me paraît pas forcément
judicieux de faire une différence entre
enseignement supérieur ray enseignements
secondaires de ce point de vue la même
sinon c'est au secondaire on l'a vu en
particulier dans les filières
professionnelles
il n'y a quasiment pas de cas de stages
de plus de six mois voilà pour toutes
ces raisons
je regrette de vous dire monsieur
godefroy que le gouvernement a émis un
avis défavorable à votre amendement
que vous avez pourtant très bien défendu
à plusieurs reprises et avec beaucoup de
conviction ensuite amendement numéro 44
proposées par monsieur barbier qui
consiste à supprimer la gratification
pour les pf mp on a déjà répondu tout à
l'heure en disant que de fait
l'organisation des formations
n'intégrait pas de stages
de plus de deux mois et que donc
ce cet amendement tombé de lui-même pour
les mêmes raisons que l'amendement
précédent pour
pour l'amendement proposé par monsieur
dsab l'écouté j'ai déjà argumenté
précédemment donc pour ces raisons un
avis défavorable du gouverneur
à ce jour merci vous demande un expert
ça me touche beaucoup et est donc en
moins un avis défavorable
l'amendement 116 opposé par monsieur
barbier et qui propose une progression
de la gratification fonction la durée du
stage et du niveau d'études du stagiaire
là c'est vraiment compliqué en plus
introduit une notion contre est bien
content et très bien expliquée par le
rapporteur et qui
ne sont pas non plus dans l'esprit de la
loi proposée ensuite l'amendement numéro
146 proposées par monsieur godefroy sur
une augmentation de la gratification
pour les mêmes raisons nous ne pouvons
pas changer tous les curseurs à la fois
et donc nous avons
émis un avis défavorable
ensuite l'amendement numéro 57
la non-obligation gratification pour les
élèves étudiants préparant des diplômes
spécifiques du secteur sanitaire social
et médico-social un donc je rappelle que
le gouvernement lors du débat à
l'assemblée nationale
percevant bien les difficultés de ce
secteur a mis en place un fonds de
transition pour aider les organismes
nouvellement soumis à gratification qui
les accueillent ce soutien financer s'il
sera réservé sûr qu'ils en feront la
demande auprès des agences régionales 1
2 sanit de santé les ars ou la direction
régionale de la jeunesse des sports et
de la cohésion sociale la drjs ps selon
la nature de l'établissement concerné
avec l'obligation de documenter
l'incapacité à s'acquitter de la
gratification et nous avons prévu pour
ce fonds transitoire un montant total de
5,3 millions d'euros qui devrait suffire
à répondre aux demandes de gratification
pendant la période transitoire
ensuite amendement numéro donc pour pour
ces raisons avis défavorable ensuite
amendement numéro 16
donc pour les raisons que j'ai indiqué
également avis défavorable
amendement numéro 82 moi il me semble
qu'aujourd'hui on a un dispositif
qui fonctionne sur la base
d'un pourcentage de taux horaire il ya
des logiciels sont prévues pour ça tout
le dispositif et est prévu ainsi et
c'est le mode de calcul qui prévaut le
modifier introduirait un élément de
complexité
vraiment important et puis ça me permet
pas non plus ça permet pas plus de
comment dire d'être en phase avec la
réalité du travail du stagiaire je
m'explique il y as on s'adonne yeux
d'ailleurs à une discussion tout à
l'heure sur un amendement qui était
proposé je crois par votre commission il
y à des lieux de stage ou la durée du
travail est de 39 heures
si si on mettait un montant forfaitaire
ça ne permettrait pas de prendre en
compte cet élément d'un mois à 39 heures
ou de plusieurs mois 39 heures donc pour
pour ces raisons
de complexité de renchérissement
potentiel du coût du stage
d'inadéquation finalement à la dure elle
effectué horaires effectués par par les
stagiaires le gouvernement émet un avis
défavorable
amendement numéro 96
pour les raisons qui ont été expliquées
par le rapporteur avis défavorable
puisque l'on encouragerait la
substitution à des emplois pour
l'amendement numéro 17
là encore pour les raisons expliquent
cité par le rapporteur même avis donc
avis défavorable pour l'amendement
numéro
60 2 oui
de rectifier terreur l'amendement dit
mieux ils sont identiques ils sont
identiques à l'eva la voilà c'est parce
que j'ai pris le premier oui exact 50 et
60 de rectifier voilà
donc un avis défavorable au bénéfice de
l'amendement proposé par le gouvernement
en coordination avec le ministère de
l'agriculture et
l'amendement numéro 95 un avis
défavorable
puisque j'ai expliqué la procédure
spécifique que nous avons mises en place
et il me semble tout à fait juste que
les stagiaires de ces formations
sociales soient gratifiées au même titre
que les autres sachant qu'en ce qui
concerne le secteur sanitaire il ya un
code le code de la santé s'applique et
là ça dépend du ministère de la santé et
un statut vraiment spécifique avec des
gratifications spécifiques et même si on
peut penser qu'elles sont sentis
insuffisante ça ne relève pas de cette
proposition de loi ça relève bien du
code de la santé et je crois même que ça
relève de la loi
hpst
merci je présente la maman
c'est bon
merci
alors nous revenons donc aux 61 rectifié
j'ai une demande de parole d'expiration
de votre madame ferrat
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre moi je souhaiterais vraiment ne
pas avoir d'arrière pensées négatives
pour autant vous nous avez dit tout à
l'heure en tout début de séance que vous
veniez simplement d'apprendre
aujourd'hui les difficultés soulevées
par les maisons familiales rurales et
vous nous dites à l'instant et à l'heure
du dîner et je pense que tout comme nous
vous avez eu deux heures pour pour cette
pause vous avez pu jouer la concertation
tente avec le ministère de l'agriculture
qu'avec les maisons familiales moi je
salue cet exploit parce que c'est
vraiment tout à fait extraordinaire
alors comme vous pensez bien que nous ne
sommes pas tout à fait prêt à entendre
cela vous tenter de nous rassurer avec
la décret moi personnellement ça ne me
rassure pas du tout je vous avoue que le
trouble dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure n'a fait que croître et embellir
depuis que nous évoquons ce cet
amendement
madame la ministre je suis désolé mais
je ne voterai pas votre amendement 150
et je maintiendrai le mien parce que ce
décret ne me rassure pas du tout si cher
collègue
monsieur revel avait demandé la parole
en même temps sur celui ci sur le 150
moi non plus je
votre part sauf même l'humaniste si vous
acceptiez
comme ça se fait assez régulièrement ici
avant de sortir le décret de venir nous
le soumettre
pour qu'on puisse regarder si ça
correspond bien à l'esprit que dans
lequel nous travaillons après tout on a
été énormément sollicité et il ya un
enjeu extrêmement fort pour ce type
d'enseignement et compte tenu des
dispositions qui sont prises non pas
qu'on fait pas confiance à
l'administration mais quand même on aime
bien savoir où on va et
je crois que prendre un décret une salle
et ont commencé un petit peu
dans cet hémicycle
très inquiet matin y'a pus un projet de
loi 100 cas un article 10 le parlement
confie au gouvernement le soin de
légiférer par ordonnances par le décret
mais c'est la même chose alors on
devient véritablement
interrogatif sur notre notre besoin
d'être ici puisque chaque fois on
demande au gouvernement de légiférer par
décret par décret ou de légiférer par
ordonnance moi je pense qu'il faudrait
au moins me mise qu'avant de sortir de
l'écran nous puissions voir une
concertation pour voir si ça correspond
bien à ce que à l'esprit dans lequel
nous essayons de travailler
meg la parole à jean claude lenoir
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre vous avez mis en appétit
avant lors du dîner lorsque entendant un
certain nombre de remarques étaient
faites un peu sur tous les bancs vous
avez annoncé qu'il y aurait un
amendement comme vous on ne le
connaissait pas le rapporteur non plus
nous avons imaginé qu'il avait nous
donné entièrement satisfaction alors
quand à la concertation je rejoins les
remarques ont été faites il ya un
instant que je sache le thème de
l'assemblée nationale a été examiné en
février je crois que c'était le 24
février dernier et dès cette époque les
maisons familiales rurales se sont
manifestés auprès du ministère de
l'agriculture
alors vous avez et ailleurs d'une façon
tout à fait les grandes que je veux se
lever
affichez votre solidarité avec le
ministère de l'agriculture en dix ans
mais ça fait deux jours que nous y
travaillons et cetera je pense que
vraiment le temps utt nécessaire pour
présenter à la haute assemblée un
amendement sur lequel nous puissions
nous retrouver car je vous le dis il eût
fallu que nous pressions la vie des
personnes qui nous ont interpellé sur ce
sujet avant de pouvoir vraiment prendre
position mois en attendant d'y voir plus
clair je me rallie complètement à
l'amendement de notre collègue charles
revêt le 62 rectifié terre qui au moins
règle le problème après tout vous avez
la possibilité en commission mixte
paritaire de revenir sur un autre
dispositif et ainsi
améliorer la concertation que vous avez
ouverte dans un dd un peu court et
arriver à une solution qui donne
satisfaction au plus grand nombre donc
je pense madame la ministre que le mieux
serait finalement bien que
souhaite ici saluer votre effort en vue
d'arriver à un compromis que le mieux
serait tellement que vous retirer votre
moment et que vous rallié à l'amendement
de notre collègue charles revêt merci
chacun avec la parole et à jb rhabiller
oui monsieur le président le ministre je
comprends bien vous avez été interpellé
sur ce qui a été dit en fin d'après midi
la solution elle est peut-être de
mécanique parlementaire c'est de
réserver cet amendement moi je suis prêt
si vous lui donnez layton teneur du
décret du nombre de mois que prévu
peut-être je ne pense pas qu'on va finir
examiné l'article 1er au cours de cette
soirée monsieur le président donc on a
jusqu'à la semaine prochaine pour
conclure cet article
le mieux ce moment je me suis prêt à
aller voter mais je pense qu'on aimerait
mieux connaître la nature du décret et
peut-être qu'on peut patienter quelques
jours
merci chers collègues je n'ai pas
d'autre demande d'expliquer si madame j
oui je crois que comme l'ensemble de nos
collègues nous avons tous été très
fortement sollicités par celles et ceux
qui animent les maisons familiales
rurales et je pense que là la
proposition de madame la ministre
associé aux demandes de nombreux
intervenants de connaître la teneur du
décret devrait pouvoir nous réunir car
je pense que le sujet est maintenant
bien connu et que nous attendons
finalement la façon dont il pourra
trouver la solution qui convienne à tout
le monde les chers collègues secrétin
gpo explications de vote
il me semble qu'il faut il faut quand
même être prudent et
aborder cette question de décret avec
beaucoup de candidats beaucoup de
maîtrise parce que dans les élèves parmi
les élèves concernés
on a des situations très différentes il
n'y a pas qu'un seul type de chaleureux
verts semblent m'a prouvé j'en suis très
heureuse même presque fier
est pour certains élèves on n'aura pas
de rémunération
pour ceux qui commencent moi j'en
connais on connaît ces situations ce
très difficile
et ça serait un terrible handicap pour
ces enfants qui ne pourraient plus
trouvé de stage et ce sont des jeunes
qui sont en grande difficulté pour
trouver une route vers une formation
donc moi je suis prudent et se dit pour
cela on peut pas avoir la même fin que
certains autres qui tout en étant en
maison familiale
sont sur des cursus gérer pratiquement
traditionnel simplement il ya une des
modalités d'accompagnement différentes
de celles qui sont ailleurs et donc moi
ça renvoie bien à un décret et à une
vraie discussion mais avec les
responsables des maisons familiales
d'après moi avec les parlementaires
mais avec les responsables des maisons
familiales parce que eux pourront
enrichir le décret de leurs spécificités
tout ce qui se passe chez eux donc moi
je suis prêt à voter
l'amendement numéro 150 la portée du
moment on nous dit que le décret
bah voilà sera discutée peut-être avec
un groupe parlementaire et puis avec les
maisons familiales je crois que c'est
quand même l'esprit est prêt mais parler
avec stéphane le foll avec une mise et
agriculture étaient dans cet esprit
aussi de dire il faut qu'on puisse
travailler avec la ministre avec ces
voix là moi je suis prêt à voter mais
qu'on nous rassure un petit peu sur la
manière dont va être rédigé le décret
merci monsieur le rapporteur voulait
intervenir
la vente est anticipé nous sommes sur
l'amendement de madame ferraille arrivé
à l'amendement 150 du gouvernement mais
c'est donc
je pense que l'amendement du
gouvernement enfin dans les auditions
que nous avons réalisés dans le monde
nombreuses qui ont été formulés répond
quand même aux préoccupations qui se
sont fait jour dans cet hémicycle
puisque quand je lis le membre du
gouvernement on dit à décret fixe les
conditions dans lesquelles il peut être
dérogé la durée minimale de sage prévu à
l'article c'est à dire du code de
l'éducation qui est d'ailleurs les deux
mois or donc les revendications des
maisons familiales rurales il souhaitait
à le porter à trois mois
donc c'était leurs revendications donc
moi je pense que le fait le fait
justement qu'il y ait une discussion
ouverte que le gouvernement ouvre la
porte à la discussion par décret avec
les maisons familiales rurales plus tôt
qu'anticipé il vaut mieux qu un dialogue
qui s'instaure entre le ministère et les
maisons familiales rurales pourraient
avoir un décret qui soit véritablement
conforme au souhait qu'ils ont formulés
donc moi je crois que c'est cet
amendement du gouvernement apporte
satisfaction si on veut gagner le
regarder de près vraiment bien j'avais
une demande d'intervention de monsieur
désessard pour explication de vote
monsieur le président j'ai bien compris
on est bien au 61 rectifié bis oui voilà
et ensuite il ya toute une
un certain nombre d'amendements et le
150 et le dernier j'ai bien compris
absolue là on a commencé la discussion
par le dernier
mais plus important pour les gens
certainement et celui qu'on attendait
depuis longtemps en tout cas
donc pour revenir aux 61 rectifié bis
alors je ne partage pas la durée puisque
je vais soutenir
l'amendement du rapporteur je crois que
ce sont 45 sur la durée d'un mois à
partir du moment où commence la
rémunération pourtant j'avais une
question donc j'ai bien compris que
madame la ministre était opposé aux 145
donc on sait pas comment va réagir cette
assemblée sur la proposition du dur à
porter mais est-ce que vous pouvez
monsieur le rapporteur me me met des
comprendre la différence entre je parle
pas de du deuxième
2ème alinéa 2 de l'amendement de
monsieur hervé mais le premier j'ai cru
comprendre que la différence dans ce
premier paragraphe par rapport à la
situation actuelle était que vous
pouviez on pouvait
apporter une rémunération au bout de
deux mois où qu'ils soient consécutifs
ou non s'ils se passe et c est ce que
c'est vraiment différent de la situation
d'aujourd'hui et si c'est vraiment
différent bien que je soutienne un mois
ci un mois n'est pas acceptée je trouve
que c'est bien qu'on puisse considérer
que le stage peut être fait en deux
parties et que c'est l'ensemble qui
amène la gratification où la
rémunération
le fait qu' est-ce que c'était ça
l'esprit de votre amendement me survit
en tout cas de la 1ère partie la
deuxième partie c'est ce que vous avez
soulever c'est la formation en milieu
professionnel qui peut être vue qui peut
être abordé donc j'avais besoin d'une
explication pour bien comprendre la
nature du premier alinéa de l'amendement
de survie est ce qui concernait le fait
que le stage pouvait découper et casse
on en prenait la durée totale du stage
pour envisager une gratification ou une
rémunération j'en profite
pour
poser la question madame le miz pourquoi
est ce qu'il ya une gratification de
stage
parce que j'ai entendu que on apportait
quelque chose à l'entreprise ou à
l'association
mais parfois on nous l'argument est de
dire qu'un stage coûte cher à l'étudiant
il va se déplacer il n'aura pas la
cantine habituel de l'établissement
scolaire il y à des frais peut-être
dhabi qui sont complémentaires enfin il
ya des frais de représentation est ce
que c'est là la notion de gratification
vient-elle du fait que ce sont des frais
induits en plus à l'étudiant ou est ce
que c'est parce qu'elle apporte quelque
chose à l'entreprise
donc moi j'aurai besoin un peu
maintenant qu'on clarifie cette question
parce que ça change beaucoup parce que
si
c'est que il ya des frais induits en
plus à ça concerne de scolaires et
l'étudiant si c'est quelqu'un qui
apporte quelque chose de l'entreprise
évidemment c'est plus près du diplôme a
priori à moins qu'il soit complètement
déformée par l'éducation nationale mais
a priori
il apporte davantage lorsqu'il est plus
près des diplômes donc voilà ces deux
questions que son rapporteur sur qu'est
ce qu'apporterait l'amendement de
monsieur reuver dans sa première partie
et que son hammam lif qu'est ce que le
pourquoi de la gratification maintenant
l'esprit de la gratification du stage
merci monsieur rapporteurs vont
intervenir
monsieur revel veut donc exclure la
gratification pour les bfmp corse et
déjà c'est déjà prévu dans le droit
actuel
c'est déjà prévu non droite une non par
l'exclusion c'est déjà prévu la
gratification et la question vous posiez
sur les 1 mois en début de 2e année
scolaire à moi enfin donc ces cas là ça
fait deux mois et c'est gratifié
c'est prévu c'est déjà dans
et il supprime la gratification voilà
merci maintenant tout est clair je vous
propose de voter sur ce 61 rectifié bis
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter veut
bien levé la main
merci avis contraire
l'amendement n'est pas adoptée sur
l'amendement numéro captor je n'ai pas
de demandes d'explications de vote j'ai
été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe crc sur
l'amendement 14 rappelle que l'avis de
la commission est défavorable ainsi que
l'avis du gouvernement il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par atik 56 du
règlement le scrutin sera ouvert dans
quelques instants
le scrutin
teclaw je demande au secrétaire de
procéder au dépouillement du scrutin
résultat du scrutin
174 sur l'amendement 14 nombre de votes
en 344 nombre de suffrages exprimés 344
pour l'adoption 20 contre 324 le sénat
n'a pas adopté l'amendement numéro 15 a
été retiré l'amendement 145 de la
commission je rappelle l'avis favorable
de la commission défavorable du
gouvernement explications de vote madame
cohen
non c'est plutôt une demande
d'explication à notre rapporteur parce
que il ya une contradiction entre
l'objet et puis la rédaction donc je
voulais le corps de plutôt de
l'amendement c'est à dire que dans le
corps de l'amendement il est il est
spécifié supérieure à un mois consécutif
et dans l'objet supérieur à tous ceux
d'entre eux deux plus de deux mois donc
il ya là je sens une contradiction
c'est un mois
comme quoi même à minuit passé on reste
attentif
et attentive
absolument donc on est d'accord très
bien nous retombe que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet amendement veut
bien levé la main
le 145
merci avis contraire
l'amendement est adopté le 44 rectifié
pas de demande d'explication non ils
tombent pas ou plus que l'autre est
adopté le fait amendement numéro 11 il
n'est pas retirée
il ne s'en remettra pas
l'amendement 116 rectifier il y avait
oui monsieur yee
moi je regrette que finalement la
commission et dans le ministre un ami un
avis défavorable sur cet amendement
pourquoi parce que à aucun moment de
cette loi on parle d'âge et quelle
différence ya dans les entreprises ou ou
même dans une exploitation agricole ou
chez un artisan quand vous avez
quelqu'un de 15 ans ou 18 ans ou de 20
ans la chose complètement différente
aujourd'hui à tellement de
réglementation qui font que même un
jeune ne peut pas monter sur un escabeau
est pas monté sur une échelle dans une
exploitation agricole où il peut pas se
servir de telles machines il peut pas
conduire un tracteur agricole avant l
âge alors la différence elle est
fondamentale alors moi je vois vraiment
pas pourquoi on n'a pas fait si on le
fait pas par l'âge pour le fassent au
moins ils varient en fonction du niveau
d'études parce que je pense que c'est
vrai que le niveau d'études il est quand
même assez proche à un an ou deux près
de l'âge donc sort était quand même une
occasion pour que des maîtres de stage
comment voulez vous qu aujourd'hui quand
vous avez un stagiaire et que vous ne
pouvez pas du tout
faire en sorte qu'ils vous par rapport à
ses obligations
je viens de citer quelques exemples est
à vos côtés et c'est pourquoi je pense
que cet amendement aurait dû être
étudier je crois que c'est vrai et dans
l'agriculture c'est vrai dans
l'artisanat c'est vrai dans beaucoup de
professions où il faut vraiment il ya un
dernier notre part aussi globalement moi
je suis quand même très inquiet sur les
obligations qu'ont mais je crois que
comme beaucoup de ses collègues vous
avez tous été sensibilisés par de
nombreux jeunes qui dit je dois faire un
stage il vous écrire c'est les parents
et les grands parents il ya mon
petit-fils et cetera qu'il faut qu'ils
fassent un sage y trouve pas des maîtres
de stage parmesan gens prendre du moins
un secteur qui est complètement bouché
dans ces domaines là c'est
l'environnement et quand vous avez
téléphoné la fédération de chasse quand
vous êtes des bonnes à la pêche quand
vous avez téléphone au parc du haut jura
quand vous téléphonez à louer en effet
très terrain et qui vous disent mais non
on a déjà des stagiaires on a déjà eh
bien comment ça va aller tout ça et moi
je suis très inquiète quand même est ce
que vraiment ce que nous votons ce soir
va vraiment aller dans le sens que nos
jeunes ne trouvent plus facilement des
stagiaires des parements des maîtres de
stage qui est aujourd'hui déjà la
difficulté ça pour soi cela cela
m'inquiète et puis je voulais revenir
quand même sur l'aim fr moi je suis
quand même surpris alors surpris que
madame le ministre nous dit c'est
aujourd'hui qu'elle l'abri alors
vraiment vraiment ya un moins que
pratiquement tous on a été contactés moi
j'ai eu 20 mai les mfr de mon
département qui sont venus me demander
ce que je les reçoivent pour dire ce
problème que cela pose est moi j'ai
quand même je suis sûr vous aussi chers
collègues il ya quinze jours un mois
voire un mois et demi que vous avez été
sensibilisés et que madame la ministre
nous disent que c'est aujourd'hui
qu'elle l'abri moi vraiment il ya des
choses que je ne comprends pas je veux
revenir à l'amendement je voterai cet
amendement parce que je crois que au
moins il tiendra compte justement de la
porte peut faire à cause des jeunes
oublions pas qu aussi qu'aujourd'hui
quand on est maître de stage
l'objectif c'est de passer du temps avec
son stagiaire pour plus haut si les
choses deviennent techniques deviennent
compliqués je dirais bien que le maître
de stage doit expliquer à son stagiaire
et doit prendre but en lui même alors il
faut bien qu'en contrepartie aussi si on
veut qu'un corps des maîtres de stage et
bien que
ces stagiaires puissent apporter bien
sur le coup de main lorsque c'était
nécessaire et travailler aux côtés du
maître de stage merci chers collègues
sur la porter
quand on parle de gratification haut
niveau en fonction du niveau d'études du
stagiaire j'attire votre attention sur
le fait que vous risquiez de pénaliser
les stagiaires les moins qualifiés parce
que le plafond légal minimum et 436
euros donc si vous voulez une échelle
progressive et de solutions où il faut
suivre les amendements déposés par nos
collègues du groupe communiste et le
mien augmentait la gratification il faut
accepter ça ou alors il faut diminuer le
minimum de gratification pour les moins
qualifiés et donc est alors je moi je
suis je pense que c'est pas tout à fait
juste d'aller dans ce sens là en plus ce
sont des étudiants déjà les faire entrer
dans la logique du système salarial de
gratification en fonction du diplôme du
temps d'ancienneté ce n'est pas ce ne
sont pas des salariés ce sont des
stagiaires quant à votre marque sur les
maisons familiales vois je voulais vous
dire dans la dg j'avais dit qu'il y
avait un souci nous en parlons depuis
longtemps moi je trouve au contraire que
nous avons une réponse aujourd'hui de
madame la ministre et du gouvernement
par le passé j'ai commencé à avoir un
peu d'ancienneté l'ancienne maison c'est
pas la première fois que le gouvernement
nous apporte des réponses en séance à
des sollicitations qui courait depuis
pas mal de semaines
merci alors je vais te vois
mais la même liste
oui monsieur le président je vais
répondre en très brièvement à votre
interrogation il se trouve qu'on a
discuté ce texte à l'assemblée nationale
et qu'à aucun moment la question des
maisons familiales rurales n'a été
évoquée c'est ainsi personne n'était
saisi ça n'est pas intervenu au cours
des débats et pourtant il ya des députés
qui sont dans des circonscriptions très
rural il y a il ya quinze jours nous
avons reçu ces colis au ministère du
travail d'une part au ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur et enfin
c'était à quinze jours donc c'était
encore le mystère enseignement supérieur
et est la recherche qui qui est devenu
depuis le grand ministère éducation
nationale enseignement supérieur et
recherche et de secrétariat d'état
actuel qu'on a reçu le courrier et on
sait on l'a renvoyé au ministère
l'agriculture en lui demandant de mener
la concertation puisqu'il s'agit des
acteurs qui sont placés sous sa
compétence
ces principes de solidarité qu évoqué
tout à l'heure le sénateur jean claude
lenoir et donc nous avons simplement mis
un certain temps avoir la réponse c'est
le temps de la réponse venant du
ministère de l'agriculture cam un
certain temps parce que la période était
une période assez peu favorable il faut
bien le dire il pas d'assez peu
favorable et qu'il fallait sûrement
prendre le temps aussi de se saisir du
sujet et la concertation comme vous
l'avez dit justement ça se fait pas en
deux heures voilà pourquoi nous n'avons
eu la réponse que très tardivement
malgré des relances parce que il y avait
ce dialogue qui n'était pas achevée
alors dans ce dialogue effectivement ce
qui a été dit c'est que d'abord le votre
amendement qui est globale
n'est pas justifiée parce qu'il est trop
globale par exemple les stagiaires dans
le milieu agricole qui sont stagiaires
dans les lycées agricoles
n'ont pas de problème de gratification
sa non ça ne pose aucun problème au
lycée agricole le problème se pose bien
uniquement pour les stagiaires qui sont
un peu moins de 20 min choix ou par 230
milles 18 lycées agricoles trente mille
dans les maisons raison rural est bien
là ça pose un problème mais dans la
discussion avec ces établissements le
ministère de l'agriculture a obtenu de
leur part l'assurance que si on passait
de 2 mois à 3 mois pour démarrer la
gratification elle en serait d'accord
c'est par précaution que j'ai préféré
vous dire il faut tout de même que dans
le décret on reprenne nous mêmes la
tâche pour être bien sûr que cet accord
est confirmée donc c'est une précaution
supplémentaire de ma part que j'ai voulu
prendre pour une réponse qui métal qui
m'est arrivé effectivement un peu
tardivement comme ça arrive souvent mais
c'est par honnêteté et transparence
envers vous j'ai voulu vous dire voilà
on voudrait confirmer on est tout à fait
d'accord pour que soit par
l'intermédiaire de la commission ou soit
pendant soit pas directement où l'on
vous fasse parvenir un texte consolidé
après après un approfondissement des
consultations et ça peut se faire assez
assez rapidement pour le coup voilà
l'explication total je m'excuse ça
prenait un peu de temps donc j'avais
fait un peu plus j'avais fait un
raccourci
merci madame la ministre
alors nous votons sur cet amendement
censeurs rectifier que ceux qui
souhaitent l'adopter veuille bien levé
la main le 116 rectifier
merci avis contraire
l'amendement n'est pas adoptée en 146 de
la commission avis défavorable du
gouvernement
d'un progressé après explications de
vote
sur cet amendement moi je m'interroge
dans la mesure où tout à l'heure on a
évoqué sur une certaine disposition
l'année de 2011 et que là bas ça
correspond absolument pas à allah ni
parce que lorsque les partenaires
sociaux se sont mis d'accord en dix ans
et des stages de six mois il aurait pu
aussi se mettre d'accord sur le plafond
qui certes n'a pas été augmenté depuis
longtemps donc puisqu'on parle toujours
de concertation est bien là aussi
j'estime qu'il aurait fallu il faudrait
un peu de concertation et il me semblait
que dans les règles que nous nous étions
fixés quand il y avait des éléments qui
concernait les entreprises ont consulté
les partenaires sociaux ça pas été le
cas là
merci chers collègues pas d'autres
demandes d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter cet amendement
veut bien levé la main
merci avis contraire
attention il est adopté l'amendement 57
rectifié bis pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter veut bien levé la
main merci
avis contraire
il n'est pas adopté l'amendement 16
tombe
l'amendement 82
avis favorable de la commission
défavorable du gouvernement
pas de demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent adopter veut
bien levé la main
merci avis contraire il est adopté
l'amendement 96 la demande
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter veuille bien levé la
main merci avis contraire
le 96 ont des
wii le cese est tombé
par l'adoption du 146
d'accord
merci
alors attendez nous en étions au
pas demandé création de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter veut bien levé la
main merci avis contraire
il n'est pas adopté l'amendement 17
il y retirer
l'amendement 50 et 60 de rectifier terre
pas de demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent l'adopter veut
bien levé la main merci avis contraire
ils ne sont pas adopté l'amendement 95
pas demandes d'explications de vote même
vote même vote l'amendement 150 du
gouvernement avec un avis favorable de
la commission assure vérification de
votre
président
il ya eu d'interrogation une suggestion
qui a été fait tout à l'heure nous avons
vous avez réussi cette performance a à
nous concocter cet amendement l'espace
de quelques dizaines de minutes
peut-être que on pourrait monsieur le
président reporter le vote de ce vin 7
rbds en demande
dès lors que en une semaine puisqu'il va
se passer une semaine vous auriez la
possibilité de nous apporter les
éléments du décret ce qui nous
permettrait peut-être à ce moment-là de
voter l'amendement vous nous soumettez
sino sinon bien entendu on va te
négativement
je vais mettre au vote chers collègues
je saute c'est la commission émet un
avis contraire mais madame la présidente
simplement oui le rapporteur me rappelle
de dire que c'est un avis du rapporteur
puisque la commission n'est en effet pas
vu cet amendement mais en même temps si
nous souhaitons que l'aura de la madame
la ministre puisse prendre un décret il
faut d'abord que nous votions le fait
que la ministre prenne un décret donc je
pense qu'il faut que nous adoptions cet
amendement est ensuite comme l'a proposé
la ministre elle pourra soit elle même
soit si elle ne peut pas venir
monsieur le foll pourquoi pas non c'est
eux
c'est monsieur le foll toujours qui est
à l'agriculture
tu viennes à la commission puisque cette
disposition concerne le ministre de
l'agriculture puisse venir nous
présenter à la commission pourquoi pas
la proposition de ce décret mais pour ce
soir il me semble que c'est important de
le voter et je voudrais puisque j'ai la
parole monsieur le président rappelait à
ma collègue catherine procaccia que nous
sommes sur une proposition de loi qui a
déjà été adoptée à l'assemblée nationale
et que dans ce cadre il n'y a pas besoin
ici de
solliciter l'avis des partenaires
sociaux quand il ya une disposition qui
les concernent d'ailleurs vous même la
semaine dernière au moment du vote sur
le dans 2 jours de congés pour enfant
malade n'avait pas sollicité les
organisations syndicales et n'avait pas
mis en oeuvre ce protocole puisque
c'était une proposition de loi qui avait
été adoptée auparavant à l'assemblée
nationale donc cette ce protocole n'est
pas à géométrie variable il s'applique
dans certaines dans certaines règles et
la règle est celle ci lorsque c'est une
ppl déjà adopté nous ne sollicitons pas
les organisations syndicales en tous cas
c'est pour ça que madame de roche n'a
pas souhaité le faire alors que j'aurais
souhaité que nous sollicitions en effet
les partenaires sociaux
merci même progression avait demandé la
parole non moi explications de vote soit
105 ans contrairement à mes collègues je
le voterai et je le voterai dans un
esprit cécilia une dérogation pour les
maisons familiales et rurales eh bien
j'espère bien que dans l'avenir la loi
prévoira d'autres dérogations pour
d'autres cas voilà pour l'examen de
cette proposition de loi visant au
développement et à l'encadrement des
stages un texte sur lequel les sénateurs
ont largement eu le vrai pour améliorer
les conditions de vie des stagiaires
avec notamment l'augmentation de leur
gratification qui est passé de 436 à 523
euros par mois finalement députés et
sénateurs sont parvenus à un compromis
sur ce texte le texte a été
définitivement adopté par le parlement à
la fin du mois de juin le 26 juin très
exactement avant d'être publié le 11
juillet dernier pouvait toujours voir et
revoir toutes les séances sur notre site
sur publicsenat.fr très bonne journée
sur les chaînes parlementaires